-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out
with Allison Williams.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go see "M3GAN" this weekend.
Allison and I are about to play
a singing version
of "The Whisper Challenge."
-Mm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct whispering ]
-Whisper Challenge.
-All right.
Now, here's how this works.
One person puts
on these headphones
with loud music playing.
And then the other person
picks up a card,
sings the song lyrics
on the card,
and the person
wearing headphones
tries to guess
what they just said, okay?
-Okay.
-All right.
So, you'll put the headphones --
you can play this at home.
-I'm going first?
-Yeah. You go first.
I'll put the song on.
-They can play it at home.
-Yeah, you can play it at home.
Sure.
If you put on headphones,
play it.
[ Laughter ]
Whenever Allison --
are you ready for this?
-I don't know.
Is it going to be really loud?
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-It's really loud.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, here we go.
-I mean, I really
can't hear you.
-Okay, perfect.
[ Whispering ]
♪ Well, shake it up, baby, now ♪
-Did it end with "baby cow"?
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-♪ Twist and shout ♪
-Oh, "Twist and Shout"?
-Wow! Yes! Yes!
-"Twist and Shout"?
Wow! That was it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-Hey, we're really good.
-Well, to be fair,
I guessed "baby cow" first.
-"Baby cow" was good, too.
-You know that famous pop song
that has "baby cow" in it?
-"Baby Shark" was big.
-In my --
By the way, in my Spotify...
-Oh, my God.
-...it's big.
-Let's write "Baby Cow," and
let's make a zillion dollars.
-That's great.
-Um, all right.
Here's a microphone for you.
-Okay.
-I should have used one,
as well.
All right, here we go.
I'm going to put this on.
-[ Echoing ] Does it do --
will it change it?
Oh. Hello.
Yes. Okay.
[ Light laughter ]
-[ Clears throat ]
-♪ You're so vain ♪
-Oh, you started?
-Yes.
-Sorry.
-I'm -- This is me starting.
-Here we go.
-I'm starting.
[ Light laughter ]
♪ You're so vain ♪
-Court -- Court vay?
[ Laughter ]
-♪ You're so vain ♪
-You're so serious.
-Vain.
-You're -- Face facts.
-Face facts.
-Face facts?
No.
♪ You're... ♪
-You.
-♪ So ♪
-Face -- No, "You so --"
-You're.
-"You're So Vain?"
-Yes! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Don't you? Don't you? ♪
-Yes!
-♪ Don't you? ♪
-Yes.
-Okay, wait, I need these.
-That song was about me.
[ Laughter ]
That's how vain it was.
I was correct --
It was about me.
Ready? Ready?
[ Chuckling ] Oh, no.
Okay.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
-A-B-C-D-E-F-U.
-I know this one!
"A-B-C-D-E-F-G"?
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"ABCDEFU"!
-Yeah, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
The -- You got -- You got --
-I got baby --
-You got baby on the brain.
You're like, "I love this song.
The ABCs?"
-The amount of --
the amount of --
-"That's my favorite song --
'ABCDEFG.'"
-The amount of pride I felt
from knowing the alphabet --
so embarrassing.
-You're like...
-"I know this one!"
-"I love this song.
We listen to it every day."
-I love this one.
It's my jam.
-It's also "Twinkle Twinkle."
-Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
-Okay.
-We've got this, bud.
-Oh, my God.
I'm so embarrassed.
Okay.
♪ You, you, you oughta know ♪
-♪ You, you, you ♪
-♪ Oughta know ♪
-You are --
you, you, you are a what?
You're an icicle?
-♪ You, you, you ♪
[ Light laughter ]
♪ Oughta know ♪
-"Heart and Soul"?
[ Laughter ]
-♪ You, you, you ♪
"Hot N Cold"?
-♪ Oughta... ♪
-Do that part.
After, "You, you, you"...
-Oughta.
-Hottay.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
You're a hottay.
-You, you, you oughta --
-You are a hottay.
-Oughta.
-Hot dad.
-Ought--
[ Light laughter ]
-"You're a hot dad."
"You, you, you are a hot --"
[ Light laughter ]
-You ought to --
-You are --
Ought.
"You Oughta Know"!
-Yes!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alanis Morissette.
Allison Williams, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her movie, "M3GAN"
is in theaters now.
Stick around.
We're talking
to Jerrod Carmichael
after the break.
Come on.